同学们好 非常感谢野羽的邀请
能够在这里给大家做一次talk 我是陆航
今天我们talk的主题是群统态加密基本原理和应用
那我今天在给大家分享的过程当中
会分享一些群统态加密的主流算法
比方说CKS它的一些基本原理
以及有关群统态加密在落地上会存在的一些问题
那么有助于大家在日后从事这个领域更深的研究
那么打下一个良好的基础
那我用这一页来做一个开场
我们国家成立了国家数据局
国家数据局提出一个概念叫做数据基础设施
那么数据基础设施包含四个类型
分别是网络设施 算力设施 流通设施
那么最后一个是我想跟大家着重强调的
叫做安全设施
这个可能是我们很少能够听到的
那么我们往往说数据它的这个主要要去做的事情
对数据做的事情
就是如何让它高兴冷的计算
那如何让它流通起来
那么但是安全
就是我们往往比较忽略的一个方面
那么国家数据局那也明确提出安全基础设施
也是数据基础设施非常重要的一个组成代源
那么安全基础设施它的一个主要职责是什么
就是用一些能够互诱数据安全的一些技术
比方说我们今天想要给大家分享的
全东太加密技术
还有比方说可信执行环境
还有比方说联邦学习
还有独方安全计算等等
这样的技术能够保证数据在流通的过程当中
绝对的安全
实现数据的流通的可用不可见
可算不可得这样一个目标
所以呢
这是数据的安全已经上升为我们的国家战略
包括国家数据局也专门去成立了一些这个机构
来去制定数据安全的一些标准
这都是对我们数据安全的一个重大的利好
好 那这一页是我从这个2022年
中国芯片大会
一位这个这个PNote的这一位专家
他的一个PPT上去解决下来的
那么从这一页上
那他是来自工业界的一位专家
那从这一页上我们可以看到
那么工业界已经普遍认为安全和隐私问题
已经成为了制约云计算发展的一个最大的障碍
那么也普遍一致认同云计算只有进入密态
才有可能最终解决用户的安全顾虑
那这里面我想跟大家提一点
这所谓进入密态
这个密态指的是什么
那我们今天给大家分享全通态加密
对不对
那么全通态加密
他主要的这个思想是把数据进入密态
是把数据通过加密的方式
让他看不见里面的明文
那么计算的时候
也是完全在密文下计算的
所以这里面的密态
我刚才所说的这种全通态加密
他的一个密态指的是数据加密以后
那么在密态下来进行计算
是这种密态的一个含义
那么同时
这个密态在这一页PVT里面
在这一页截图里面
他的这个意思可能略有不同
他指的这个密态是也可能是明文
但是我只要触碰不到这个明文
或许不到这个明文
他就是处在一种保密的
或者说机密的状态之下
所以这里面我想跟大家说这样一个概念
那么现在我们说数据
所谓密态计算可能有两种
一种是以可信执行环境为代表的机密计算
那它也算是密态
一种是以全通态加密为代表的密态计算
那它俩有本质的不同
那么核心执行环境是在明文的情况之下
通过我们计算系统的软硬件协同起来
保护明文在计算系统里面安全的执行
比如说我可以通过隔离的方式
把他的计算环境和其他
我不可信的应用隔离开
那这是所谓的一种密态
而我们今天所要分享的是另一种密头
通过一些密码学的一些算法
比如说全通态加密算法
把数据实现加密
我可以在加密以后
让任何人接触不到里面的明文
也破解不出里面的明文
这是另一种密态
它的一种表现形式
也是我们今天主要的分享的一个方面
好那么刚才已经提到了
我们这种密态是基于现代密码学的
一种数据保护
它可以工作在不可信的硬件上
也就是说你计算机上有很多
恶意的程序想要去获取你的
这个想要保护的信息
但是我们一旦通过全通态加密的方式
把它加密起来
那就是绝对安全
我也可以运行在这些不可信的硬件上
也可以和一些不可信的应用
一起运行在计算系统上
那么忽悠这种数据绝对安全状态之下的
加密算法
加密还能够计算的算法
就叫做全通态加密
它最核心的一个特色
就是在密文域上可以进行任意的计算
那么这个任意的计算
可能让你觉得有一点奇怪
可以进行什么样任意的计算
那么实际上我们情况下加密
它是只支持密文状态下的惩法和加法
但是我们学过泰勒吉术对不对
那么惩法和加法这种现行计算
可以擬和一切非现行的计算
所以这里面就是所谓的通过惩法和
在密文下进行惩法和加法的计算
来去实现任意的非现行的计算
好 那我看这页图
明文域它指的是有两个明文
一个是A 一个是B
通过全通态加密的方式
把它加密为密文A和密文B
在密文域上我们可以做密文的计算
那么这个F就是我们在密文下
所做的任何计算
比如说我可以做一个神经网络的
ReLU这个函数对不对
那么通过多样式的
通过密文的乘客家
这里面有多次提到多样式
是因为我们加密以后
它就会变成一个多样式
这一会我们再详细的去讲解
那么通过密文下的计算
去实现任何F它的一个计算
那么计算完了以后
得到了一个密文的结果C
在对C进行解密以后
得到实际的明文计算的
在F下计算的结果是一模一样的
这样一个效果
所以我们可以看到
如果我们的明文是我们的隐私数据
那么我把它发送到云端
在云端上做一些保护隐私前提之下的
一些计算
然后再把计算完了结果
以密文的形式返回
那么在我们的本地把明文再解密出来
所以在整个传递的过程当中
明文是没有任何泄露的
只有在本地才能够解密出
它实际的明文结果
所以这就是它最大的一个好处
那么成功态加密它的一个发展
经历了这么几个阶段
实际隐私同态的概念
是早在1978年就提出来的
北极升阶陆这个发展
就是提出极升阶陆这样一个
北极升阶陆的创始发明
它的时间上还是差不太多的
都是在70年代
那么都是一个非常年轻的学科
对不对
那么在90年代的时候
出现了半同态的算法
半同态就是说我们在F的计算的时候
只能是加法
在密文状态下做加法
那么结果是返回以后结果是解密以后
和明文结果是一致的
只能做加法
在密文状态下做加法
那么结果是保持一致的
那么不能做其他的运算
那么全同态指的是
刚才我也提到过
在密文状态下做加法和乘法
而且是任意次数的加法和乘法
那么都可以结果保持一致
所以如果能够做惩罚和加法
那么它理论上就可以支持任何计算
对不对
因为任何的这个非信心的计算
都可以通过乘和加来进行理合
比如我刚才提到的胎乐技术
就是做这样一件事情
那么全同态
刚才已经说了
可以在密文状做任意次数的加法和乘法
那么它的算法发展
也经历了这么几个阶段
比如说在2012年
首先全同态的概念是根锤
是我们这个算法
它的一个发明人
或者是太斗级的人物
我还记得之前
有人评论说能够看懂
干脆的毕业设计论文
全世界的没有几个
所以是非常有意思的一个事情
那么2012年的时候
出现了基于整数加密的
驱动态加密的算法
也就是说我想
把这些刚才我提到的这个
明文给它加密
那么明文只能是整数
好
那么2015 2016年
出现了FHE
W和TFHE这样的算法
那么它是加密一个比特
比整数的这个力度要更细
加密一个比特
那么一个比特
一个比特的这种加密
那么它是可以理解为
是布尔形对不对
比个比特
它是布尔形的全同态加密算法
2017年出现了CKS
那么CKS是可以加密
相比BFHE的BGV
它更先进一些
它可以加密这个实数
实数就有小数对不对
比如说一个实数
一个小数
比如说加密个2.4
也可以加密-5
那么-5就比如说1加2i
一会我们看一个例子
那我也可以通过
全台加密的CKS的算法
来进行加密
那么BFHE BGV
以及CKS
我们可以统称为这个
数值型的
或者算数型的
算数型的全台加密
所以我们全台加密算法
往往分为两类
一种是算数型的
一种是布尔型的
那么全台加密它的作用
非常的大
那么它也在工业界
也起到了非常重要的
隐私保护的作用
那么这里面就简单说一下
那么如果一个云服务的提供商
可以确保
比如说对你来承诺
我可以保证你的数据
绝对安全
那我可以去完全信任它
对不对
所以可以降低信任成本
而且处在全部的
密闻计算的前提之下
我也不用去额外的
去做什么安全的设施
安全的技术
去再进一步的保证
因为它所有的计算都在密闻
看不见明闻
所以我可以降低
我的安全保护的成本
对吧
所以它的好处是很多的
那么它的使用场景
简单提一下
比如说我做一个
人脸的识别
那比如说现在我们蚂蚁
也就是银语所在的这个蚂蚁集团
它就有这样的需求
那我想对用户的一个
一个使用习惯
做一下推荐
那我就可以把用户的
这些使用习惯
做一下这个加密
因为这是属于你的隐私
那么把这个加密以后的数据
发送到云端
我们做一个密泰下的一个推荐系统
做密闻下的一个推理
那么给出你可能会
喜欢的一些商品的信息等等
那再比方说
我们在这个刷脸支付的时候
那么人脸属于你的敏感息息
对不对
那么把人脸息息
用群能态加密的方式做一个加密
那么也就是说
我传递到云端
我是看不到你的人脸
然后呢
在他的数据户里边
人脸对应你的账户
对不对
那我可以在密泰下
进行一个对应账户的一个查询
那么从而实现扣费
在密闻下
直接密泰下
直接进行那个支付的一种扣费
这过程当中
被任何人结合
都看不到你的人脸的明文的信息
对不对
所以这也是非常有用的一种
这个场景的应用
好
那么我们在具体讲
他的算法之前
我们先看一个例子
那么这里面我要提一句
就是我在接下来讲
这个方面算法的时候
我避免采用这种
比较八股的方式
来给你一味的去
讲解每一个公式
它到底是什么意思
避免采用这样的方式
那么我们会通过一个例子
来让你直观的看到
这个群能态加密算法
它到底是怎样来进行工作的
那么我所举的这个例子
就是PIR
这个PIR它的意思是
也逆查询
或者也叫密探查询
或者也叫逆中查询都行
它的一个主要思想
是在把你的检索的
要查询的相量
比方说是你的人脸信息
或者你的身份信息
把这个信息加密
然后到云服提供商的数据库里边
在密探下
去把你要的信息
有关于你的信息
给它检索出来
所以是查询的过程当中
看不到查询的人是谁
对不对
那么查询的
被查询的方也看
被查询的方
看不到查询的人是谁
那么查询的方
也看不到
除了你要查询的东西以外
其他被查询的方
有的其他数据
那也看不到
所以对双方来说
都是数据安全的
也说你只能得到
你要的结果
对吧
那么被查询的方
也看不到
你要查的东西到底是啥
所以双方
都是一个保密状态下的
一个查询
那么查询这种状态之下
还能够查询到
你想要的结果
所以这叫密态查询
好吧
这里面密密麻麻的文字
留给大家做参考
好 那我们看一下
基于情侣态加密的密态查询
如何形式化
如何进行构造
那么假设
被查询方的数据库里面
有2048条数据
2048条数据
而你要查询的
所以它是一个敏感数据
也就是需要
对它进行全同态加密
那么
目前你所看到的这个
所以它是一个名文
是为了让大家能够清楚的看到
这里面有什么内容
如果变成密文的话
你就不知道里面是什么了
这就是它加密以后
就把数据给隐藏了
所以这里面
我通过这个
所以把它变成
明文的形式
来让大家更好的理解
到底是怎么查询出来的
比方说
你这个数据在没加密
所以在没加密之前
它的一个值
是一个one halt的
所谓one halt
就是说
我要只有一个数据是一
那么这个一代表的是
第二个
我要查询的这个条目
简单的一个sample
那么其它是零
就代表
我是不需要知道
其他人的信息的
我只需要知道
在你的数据户里边
第二条
也就是说我们这里面
第一
这样的一个数据
把它想要查出来
那么
这个如果把index加密
那么在被查询方
它不知道要查的是
第一这一列
对不对
就是它比较好的地方
能够保护这个
查询方
它自己的index
保护这个
所以
在明文状态下
我现在知道了
我要查询的是
第一这一列
因为第一
在index里面
它代表的是一
是one halt的
我怎么去查询出
第一这一列呢
这里面
首先要把index
进行编码和加密
我先说一下
它的大概的一个流程
之后
我们再详细的去看
怎么编码怎么加密
那么
首先我肯定要把
index进行编码和加密
那么加密
它变成密文
对不对
编码给它编码
成一个多相式的形式
而不是原始的这样
明文的香料
对不对
把它编码成一个
多相式的形式
然后对多相式
进行加密
之后
我们再详细的去
举个例子
再去讲这个问题
好
那么
第二个
就是
这个
被查询方
它要把它的自己的
这样一个数据库
要进行一下重新的变形
那么方便
通过
密探查询的方式
把第一这一列查询出来
因为我在被查询方
所要变形目的
就是为了让
查询方
能够在密探的情况之下
能够方便你做一个查询
能够构造出
你能够在密探下
查询出来的
这样一种
数据库的
数据的形式
那比方说我们把
所有的数据
有2048
这样的条目
那么每一个条目
可能也是一个2048行
或者说我把这个矩阵
定这个矩阵
变成一个
2048行
2048列的一个矩阵的形式
这样可能说起来
更方便一些
那么我们首先
对它进行对角化
那么所谓对角化
就是按照对角线
把数据取出来
那么比如说
我们这个正好
是一个2048行
2048列的
那是这样一个方证
对吧
那么正好每一条数据
每一个条目
也是有2048个数据
我们通过对角化的方式
把每一个列
它的数据
都
把每一个对角线上的数据
都变形为
每一个列的数据
举证的每一列
所以你看
如果是绿色的
代表的是
这个举证的
主对角线
对不对
再一个弄
那么
蓝色的
就代表的是
它的临近的
第二个对角化
对第二个对角
是
不和它比0的
这条对角线上的
它的一个数据
那这里边可能会
以后可能会有疑问
这里边不是少了一个吗
少一个
把这个D0
这一列的
比如说D2047
对不对
D0
这一列
作为这个
蓝色的它最后的
这一个数
这里边没有写出来
也说如果不够的话
我从这左边
这边去取
比如说D2
这一列
少两个数
那就是它和它
对不对
这个准确的说
这个位置和这个位置
不是D03
这个位置
这到处第二个数
和D1这一列的
到处第一个数
对不对
对角化了以后
相当于我
我举证做了一下变形
那么变形完以后
又要怎么办呢
比方说
这个时候我要把
D1这一列的
所有数据查寻出来
如果是明稳的话
那我不用做什么变形
对不对
我直接把D1拿出来就行
因为我知道
你要查的是D1列
那现在我们D1
这个索引
这个
都是加密的
比如说index
我用这一列来表示
每一个数都是B0
都用B来表示
比如说D1的数B0
它就等于0
对不对
B1等于1
B2等于0
B3等于0
所以现在的问题就是
我
这里面所有的B
我是看不到
所以我必须通过
一定的构造
能够方便让查寻方法
这个D1这一列
给它查寻出来
好
现在我要做的一件事情是
把索引和我变形以后的
每一个列
进行同态惩罚的运算
同态惩罚的运算
指的是
每一个点
它的
每一个索引的
每一个位置
每一个对应位置相乘
那我们还是
假装我们知道明稳
比如说B1等于0
B0等于0
B1等于1
那么它俩相乘完以后
得到结果
那大家一看就知道是什么
那么
这一项就是0
对不对
因为B1等于1
那么这一项
它就把它检索出来了
对不对
这一项保留
那么后边
这些都是0
对不对
所以你发现
通过对角化以后
我和索引
来进行相乘
是密台下的
所以我不知道
我要查的是哪一个
但是
反映到明稳上
假装
我知道
B1是我要查的
那么这样的计算
你会发现
我把我要感兴趣的那一列
就是第一这一列
我就可以给它查讯出来了
对不对
好 接下来要做的一件事情
第三个步骤
旋转
那个旋转指的是
对于索引来进行旋转
原来我们B0
是在这个index的
第0个位置上
现在我要把B1
放到第0个位置上
那么B0去哪
旋转之后
到下边了
对不对
一个循环到下边了
到第2048个位置上
对吧
所以旋转以后
再一次和第2列
来进行相乘
这时候你发现
第2列正好是
第10所在的位置
和B1
抽完等于1的
对不对
把第10给它取出来了
刚才是把第1
这一个给它取出来了
现在是把第10给它取出来了
然后取出来之后
那么其他的自然都是0了
对不对
因为B2 B3 B4
都是0
对不对
然后你看
我把我感兴趣的那一个元素
在它的被查詢上的数据库里边
把这个条目就给它查询出来了
那么同样再旋转
那这时候发现
你发现B1看不见了
对不对
那B1到哪里去了
旋转到最下边的位置上
对不对
那么如果你仔细的去
再思考一下
你会发现
我们旋转到
最下边那个位置
实际就是我们
第1的什么
2048那个位置
对不对
第1 2047
那个那个纸
也是第2048个
第1的纸
那个位置
所以呢
他们在做相乘
正好把最后一个数也取出来了
好
这里面你看
我取出来的是
通过这样的一个运算
第10 第11和第1 2047
其他的所有的数都是0
对不对
是不是
好了
那
这个是怎么得出来的呢
我把每一个
我感兴趣的D
取出来以后
把他们再做
同态的加法
对不对
你想同态的加法
我们虽然看不到
密台下
他是怎么样去做的
但是明文的状态之下
那我把第1取出来了
剩下都是0
对不对
这个我把第10取出来了
剩下的都是0
这个我把第1
2047取出来了
剩下的也都是0
那么他们相加
自然就是
我画
红框的
这样一个相量结果
对不对
好了
那这只是其中
我举的例子的第1组
好
那么
我们把所有的
经过举证
对角化以后的
都按照这种方式
去和
所有
以及旋转以后的
所有进行相乘
把得到的结果
所有的都加起来
那我就会得到
所有的
和第相关的数据
对不对
希望这个过程
我给大家讲清楚了
那这里面
你会发现
我们做这样的一个例子
特别麻烦
对不对
本来是一个很简单的
一个查询
但在密台下
我就要做这样一个
复杂的一个过程
它需要经过这么几个步骤
总结一下
上一页的
编码加写完之后
和这个
被查询方的数据相乘
成完之后
旋转
对不对
称一次
旋转之后再同态加
加完的结果
比如说
是一个密文
对不对
这个密文就是我要查询的结果
我再返回给查询方
查询方要做
解密和解码
对吧
最后得到
第的实际的名文纸
这是他要查询的纸
在这个过程当中
你会发现
被查询方是不知道
是这个查询方的索引的
因为所有的这里面
B0,B1,B2,B3
都是加密的
只不过是为了
方便大家理解
所以我把它这里面
放到假装里知道名文
对吧
然后查询方
除了查到第1
这一列
也就是他感情的纸以外
其他所有的
第2,第3,第4
他都查不到
对不对
所以这是一个
非常简单的
两方进行
密态查询的这样一个例子
这里面涉及到的
所有的同态
下载运算
我们接下来
会逐一的来讲解一下
那么我们用的算法
就是CKS
这样的算法
好,我们看一下
CKS的基本语言理
那么这里面
涉及到很多公式
那么我会用
非常让大家
亦理解的语言
去讲解
那么大家
如果对这里面的符号
有些不是很清楚的
那么可以自行
去查阅相关的文献
那么我们首先看一个
编码和加密的
这样的一个步骤
首先
算法
不管是什么样的算法
都是有它的参数配置的
比如说这里面
我要配置的是一个
这么几个参数
举个例子data
它代表的是缩放的大小
再比方说n等于4
这里面表示的是
我们加密以后
密文的多项式
包括编码以后
明文的多项式
它的最高次数
就是3次方
也就是说
不超过4
对不对
多项式的最高次数
是3次方
好
多项式
次数是3次方
那么它一共有多少个系数
有4个系数
对不对
比方说我这里面写一下
比如说a0加a1x
加a2x平方
加a3x的3次方
这里面一共有4个系数
对不对
所以这n等于4
叫多项式的degre
degre
好
那么这里面
我们看一下
首先我们要做的一件事情
是
比如说我们要
编码和加密
两个项量
这也简单一个三谱
是3加4i和2-1i
刚才我们说
cxs是可以针对
时数的
也可以针对复数的
对不对
好
那么3加4i和2-1i
我们对它进行
编码和加密
这是第一步
把它编码为一个
明文的多项式
在编码为多项式以后
再对它
这个明文的多项式
进行加密
这是我们
要做
这个cxs
进行
密探查询的第一步
对不对
不管是
做什么样的运用
这都是第一步
好
那么我们怎么样
对它来进行编码呢
首先取
84本源单位根
这里边有一个概念
这里面还是那句话
对不对
为了避免
然后大家觉得很复杂
那我画一个图
你就知道
什么叫本源单位根
比如说
画一个图
所谓
单位根
它的意思
比如说这里面
我取84的单位根
先不管本源
那么84单位根
指的就是
把一个圆平均8等分
对不对
那8等分
已经是这个了
对吧
我画的这个每一个点
8等分
1 2 3 4 5 6
对不对
画错了
1 2 3 4
这个
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
没错
是吧
是8等分
好
这个
我们看一下这个
8等分
它比如说这里面是
这个
可 c 0
这是可 c 1
就在这个点上
这是可 c 2
然后一直到可 c 7
对不对
8等分
那么所谓
84本源
这8个值
都是它的单位根
对不对
我们学过这个
单位源上
级等分
那么
本源单位根指的是什么呢
这里边跟的这个编号
跟的这个编号
和8互置的那些
你就记住这一点就可以
互置的那些
比如说1
当然1和8互不互置
也算
对不对
因为它们之间
互置的意思是什么
只有公银子是1
对吧
所以互置
3互不互置
互置
5互不互置
7互不互置
对不对
所以和8不可约的
它们是互置的那些根
所以你就记住就行
所谓取它的8次本源单位根
那么对于两个数的时候
取它的8次本源单位根
那么
如果是
我们要编码加密
4个明文的数
需要几次呢
留给你做参考
留给你做思考
好吗
好
那么你只要记住
这里面取的是
如果是
这个Degrease 4
只能
编码和加密
两个数
同时我们要用
8次本源单位根
这是我们需要的
那8次本源单位根
一共是几个
4个
对不对
分别是以8互置的
那4个数
好
那么接下来我们编码
编码是把一个幅数相量
把它编码到一个
整数多项式上
好
那么这里面
复杂的一个符号
比如说
这是什么意思
对不对
我先不讲
可以吧
然后我们
看看它的直观步骤
再来对它进行理解
先知道它步骤都是怎么做的
首先我们把一个
编码的
要编码的实数
就我们这里面的
3加4i
和2-1i
把它进行扩展
这个扩展
在我们CxS的论文
原文里面叫做
硬设
这个硬设是
PineZ
这个硬设
但是你不理解
这个概念没有关系
我们先知道
所谓的扩展
就是把两个数变成
怎么把它
有两个数变成四个数呢
就是把两个数
由幅数
扩展为它的
共恶幅数
比方说3加4i
后面就3-4i
2-1i就是2加1i
那如果是实数呢
比如说这是2
这是3
那我把它扩展怎么扩展
再写一遍
倒着写
这是3
这是2
懂了吧
所以这就是
第一步
把它进行扩展
第二步
进行这个
缩放
这里面用我们的
缩放因子data
来进行缩放
这里面对于
有些不了解CKL的同学
可能
或者不了解全国泰加密的同学
可能不知道
为什么要进行缩放
缩放的意思是
让它能够保持一定的精度
你先记住我这句话
之后我们在看到的时候
我们再来
详细的去解答这个问题
那么缩放
比如说我们的data
取的是64
这是我们预先设定好了
缩放的因子
缩放的参数
这个值都乘以64
那就得到这个
缩放以后的
它的
我要编码的这四个数
其中主要的是前两个数
对不对
后两个数是它的功额
那接下来
这个编码的过程
它就是一个叫
叉值的过程
叉值过程具体是做什么
那么我们首先
把我要编码的这四个数
扩展以后的这四个数
把它变成多相式的
四个
得到的结果
四个值
那比如说
它将是按照如下的这种方式
来进行构造
对吧
那么这些可c
就是刚才我们所说的
所谓的它叫
本源单位根
对不对
一共是四个本源单位根
分别是可c
可c的三字方
可c的五次方
可c的八次方
sorry 七次方
好了
所以我把它
带入到我们的
多相式里面
a0加a1x
加a2x的平方
加上a3x的三字方
我们把x
分别用这四个值来进行
带入
那我肯定会
得到四个结果对不对
那么也就是说
我们编码的过程
就是通过
这四个根
以及
我们要编码的这几个数
反过来
求这个多相式的
系数的过程
对不对
好了
那我把它用这种
矩阵的形式
来予以展示
那么你会发现
这就是两个矩
就是一个矩阵
乘以一个相量
得到另一个相量的过程
好了那接下来
我就可以根据
矩阵求逆的方式来求得
这些
这个a0
一直到a3这四个数
对不对
所以呢
我们利用
这个矩阵的性质
来进行求值
那么求值的过程就是
我们利用这个
这个矩阵
把它求逆的这样一个
预算的法则
把它求逆
因为我们知道
所有的sata
对不对
所以我们就可以求逆
求完逆以后
我们利用这个
翻得蒙矩阵
那么整个这个矩阵
大家知道一下就可以
那么利用
翻得蒙矩阵的性质
那么求逆的过程
它就可以等一下
为这样一个过程对不对
好了
那么万事俱备
我们就可以求得
a0到a3的值
就是这四个数
你会发现
如果我们把它扩展
成共恶以后
那么
它本身就有一个
非常好的一个特性
就是最后你求得的
这个a0到a3
它就是一个整处
不再是复数了
这是为什么
我们要之前把它
通过共恶的方式
来进行扩展
这个道理
好
那么再进行取整
得到的整数系数
是这四个系数
好
这个就非常简单了
对不对
所以最后得到
编码多样式
就是它
好
那么如果你把
这个c
这些根
四个根
分别带入进去
你发现
就是这四个值
我们同学们
可以自己去自行
验证一下
对还是不对
好了
那么接下来
编码完了之后
我要进行加密
加密是非常有讲究的
大家提一点
就是加密的
这个过程当中
是需要保证
一定的安全性
因为你加密的目的
就是不被人破解
对不对
那么同态加密
里面有非常重要的
一条
就是保证
它的安全等级
比方说
有128比特安全
好
192比特安全等等
这里面
我们只要保证
128比特安全
就相对来说
是比较安全的
所以一般
我们在论文里
或者是在
实际应用当中
就
大家都是保证
128比特的安全即可
那所谓128比特
它的安全指的是什么呢
就是你在2的128四方
这样的时间之内
你是破解不了
它的明稳的
所以这个时间
已经足够长了
所以你在这么长的时间之内
你是破解不到里面的明稳的
所以就足够能保证
它的安全性
好
那我们怎么能够达到
128比特的安全呢
这个图就给了你一个参考
这个图
它的意思就是
这个
Degre
也就是这个N
这个N
可以是
因为你要编码数很多
对不对
所以刚才我们举的例子
是两个数
那如果要编码
大概
8000个数
对不对
或者编码什么
1万个数
那我这个N
应该取得多大呢
对不对
你就可以知道
至少要保证
它乘2的大小
对不对
比如说我要编码
16384个数
对吧
那我肯定
这个N
要取32768
这样一个横轴的位置
要保证它在
128比特的安全性
保证之内
那么我们
密文一下的
密文的魔术
要取多少呢
那一定是在这个
这条直线的
向下这个区间
比如这个CQ的区间
所以你发现
它密文的魔术
最大可以取到
800多个比特
对不对
这个图率
可以给你们一个
确的体现出来
好
所以你要保证
它128比特的安全性
前级之下
你来确定N和Q
那么这个N就是
多样式的Degre
刚才讲到了
那么这个Q是什么意思
就是密文的魔术
这个Q
所以LOGQ
就是多少个比特
二个多少次方
对不对
好
这里面我们举的一个例子
很简单
这个Q很小
就是65537
很小
那么Q一般是
取是一个质数
或者叫速数
对吧
大家都知道
也就是说我们在
每次进行多样式
运算的时候
密文
它的多样式
加密以后
这个密文的魔术
那也就意味着什么
你在每次运算完结果之后
都要
把每一个系数
对这个密文魔术的
进行取魔操作
好
那么
我们具体看这个例子
比如说我们
明文多样式
是这样一个
结果
刚才已经得到了
好
那么我们取私要
这是我们加密的密要
然后造声
然后造声是为了
怎么样
在这个
因为我们全台加密
是采用这种
隔极密码的方式
对不对
那么造声加到
我们的这个结果里面
它就会
增加这个破解的难度
这个我不详细展开讲了
那么这里面
这个造声多样式
实际多样式
那么是它的一个叫
研码
对吧
就是我们
在密码学里边
经常说的研码
好
那你发现我们的加密
实际上操作起来
非常简单
就是由负的
AS加M加E
那么M就是我们这里面的
明文多样式
那么S
就是我们的私要
对不对
A就是研码
加上一个造声
来增加它的安全性
好
那么得到一个结果
B
那么多样式你发现
这密文多样式
它都是成对出现的
那么我们加完密以后
原来的一个M
明文
现在变成了一对密文
或者说一个密文
里面有两个多样式
分别是B和A
主意要模Q
它的系数
必须小于6537
好
那么在编码加密以后
我们接下来要做的事情
是同态惩罚
同态惩罚
包含两种类型
一个是密文
明文成
皮帽子
一个是密文
密文成
好
那么密文
明文成
那么
它相对操作来说
比较简单
那么刚才我们说
C是一个密文
密文包含两个多样式
一个是B
一个是A
那么M
是另一个明文
那么他们之间
做惩罚
就直接两个多样式
分别相乘
就可以了
好
那么结果
MPMOT
它的结果
你在进行解密以后
发现它的结果
和两个明文成的结果
是一致的
所以这个相对来说
比较简单
接下来
密文密文成
是
假设用同样的CLS
所加密的
两个密文
一个是C1
一个是C2
首先
你一定要确保
注意一点
模术一定是一样的
在同一个模术之下
你才能做
密文密文成
记住了吗
好
那么密文密文成
它比密文密文成
就要复杂很多
那么密文密文成
它会得到
三个多样式
这是为什么呢
比方说我们C1
它是由B和A1组成的
C2是由
C1是由B1A1组成的
C2是由B2A2组成的
那么他们之间相乘以后
那么根据我们
多样是惩罚的预算法则
你会发现
他们惩罚以后
会多出来一下
所以我们分别用
D0,D1,D2来进行表示
对它进行解密
也会多出来密要的一个
另一个密要
那么就是s方这个密要
那么你对它进行解密
分别用s和s方
按照这种方式来进行预算
你发现结果就是m和m
对吧
所以正确性是得以保证的
但是这里面有一个
问题
就是每一次相乘以后
密闻的维度
就会增加一个多样式
对不对
乘一次增加一个多样式
再乘一次
又增加一个多样式
所以就意味着
你要解密用的密要
也会增加
对吧
原来是只有一个s
现在你要用s
s方
s三四方等等等等
所以
那么也就是说
你密闻做惩罚
你要做多少次惩罚
你就要有很多个密要
来进行解密
所以这个过程非常的麻烦
对吧
密要的存储
等等
开销
所以这个怎么办呢
所以在CVPS的
它的一个论文里面
或者它这个算法里面
就提出了一个
叫重现性化的一个概念
所以我觉得
这是我们CVPS的算法里面
非常精彩
非常巧妙的一个地方
那么我们怎么能够
把第二这一项
给它消除掉
把它揉到
第零和第一这两项里面
那么最终
我就可以用一个密要
s来进行解密就可以了
好 那么具体怎么做呢
我想实现重现性化
要有一个辅助密要
也有人管的叫
重现性化密要
叫EVK
EVK注意
这里面它的大小
是在PQ的范围之内
所谓PQ
那么它的魔术就不是Q了
而是在PQ的范围之内
它的魔术更大
这里面为什么多出了一个P
就专门是为
这种重现性化
所额外引入的
另一个大魔术
好 那么我们看
整个这个BPR
APR
分别是怎么计算的
那么BPR APR
分别是在PQ范围之内的一个
特别大的一个数
你可以想象一下
非常非常大的一个数
好 那么
我们把s方
用s来进行加密
那么它的加密方式
就自然是这样
想一想
这个加密的方式
是不是和我们对明文加密
它的做法是非常的相似的
非常的similar
对不对
只过把这一下
原来我们是m嘛
这一下变成P乘以s方的
相当于对P乘以s方这一项
用我们的s来进行加密
好 加密完以后
得到一个BA
就是我们的重现性化密钥
辅助密钥
好 那么我们做
重现性化的过程是怎么样子呢
对于第二这一项
乘以重现性化密钥
再乘以P的Ni
因为这里面
乘了一个P
这里面乘了一个P的Ni
是为了把它还原回来
好 那么我们再看
具体这样做的结果
它的正确性怎么样进行保证
好 那么比如说
我们对于这一项
把它放到这里来
那么PNi乘以D2乘以EVK
对不对
这是我们原始的密钥s
它们之间做内机
看看是不是能够得到
D2s方这一项
如果能够得到D2s方
那它的结果和之前的结果
就是一样的 对不对
好 那么我们PNi乘以D2B
把它展开 对不对
做内机
内机就是把它直接
做成绩球合
把它展开
然后呢
再具体把这个B皮
进行展开
得到是这一项 对吧
好
然后呢
加上
这一项不变直接过来
对吧
好了 那么把它再进行运算
这里不详细讲解了
得到结果就是s方D2
加上PNi乘以D2
再乘以一个E
好 你会发现
这里面PNi和D2相比
D2是在什么范围之内
D2它是属于
R Q
这样一个范围之内
它是摩Q的
对不对
那么P
往往取约等于Q
好 那么所以
D2这一项和P
基本上是在同一个大小
对不对 基本上是在同一个大小
所以D2和PNi
基本上就相互抵消掉了
只剩一个非常小的一个噪声
约等于s方D2
看到了吧
所以在重新进化的过程当中
会引入噪声
但是噪声引入的很小
所以约等于原来的这一项
就是保证了它的一个正确性
好了 那这里面就是
重新进化它的概念
好 那在重新进化以后
同态成的最后一个步骤
就是重缩放
重缩放它的作用
就是减少密闻中存在的噪声
在操作层面上
它非常的简单
就是在相成以后的密闻的技术之上
除掉我们最开始那一页
所设置的一个缩放音子
起到减少噪声增长的一个目的
那么在操作层面下
就是C除以一个data就可以了
非常的简单
好 那么我们进入到第三个步骤
就是旋转
那么旋转在刚才那个PR的例子里面
是用于提取你所感兴趣的
那些背查学方它的数据
比如说提取第一那一列
我就要把我的加密以后的所有
进行相应的旋转来提取
来提取第一那一列里面的每一个元素
好 那这个旋转能不能直接
对密闻的系数来进行旋转呢
那肯定是不行的
因为密闻的系数旋转
会破坏里面的名文
所以在我们的CKS下
旋转是有它规范的步骤的
那么旋转最终达到一个效果
那么具体说来
就是还拿我们刚才PR那个例子
来举个例子
把我们的B0 那个B1
这个B2等等
这个它的这个縮影
变成B1 B2 B3等等
也像那把B1挪到原来B0的位置
那么具体说来呢
假设原来是0 1 0 0 0 0
现在变成1 0 0 0 0 0 0
对吧 先把1旋转到原来0那个位置上
然后用来提取我感兴趣的
第一那一列里面的某一个元素
那么旋转它非常的复杂
但是它可以分为两个步骤
我们只需要记住这两步骤也就可以了
第一个步骤叫做自同构
自同构
自同构的意思是把原来的密文
多样是里面的每一个x
变成x的5的k字方
摩托2nk代表的是旋转的不长
旋转不长
那么k等于2
k等于3 k等于4
表示分别左旋
两位三位四位
对不对
那一般就是k等于1
能相当于把b1移到原来的b0的位置上
左旋移位
对吧
好了 那么我们既然对原来的多样式
它的这个位定元
从x变成了x的假设
旋转移位就变成了x的5次方
好 那么我们要保证解密以后
能够正确的解密
我们还要引入一个旋转密要
和刚才我们重新进化密要
有一点类似
但也不同
旋转密要
它就是把原来的原始密要s
这个多样式
也变成对应的形式
把它的位定元
也变成x的5的k次方
摸完2n这种方式
好 那么从这里边
你就可以看到
我想旋转几次
那么也就需要几个密要了
对不对
因为我每次这个k不同
导致我密要就要增加
所以旋转它的一个
核心的思想
是一个圈奉问题
那么比如说我想旋转5次
那我就要旋转
我就需要5个旋转密要
对不对
那么也就会增加
我的密要的存储
那如果我要旋转40很多
每旋转一个步骤
每旋转一个步长
我都要存一个密要的话
那我的密要就会很多很多
对吧 那么我们都知道
在密台下
这个密要它的长度
它的大小是非常非常大的
往往是几十兆
占了一个量级
所以我要存的越多
那占用我的存储空间
肯定就会越大
所以为了避免这个问题
我可以采用一种全红的方式
我只需要存2的密一次
不长的旋转密要
比如说我旋转2的零次方
那就是1次
我旋转密要为1
可以等于1下的旋转密要
可以等于2下
可以等于4下
这种旋转密要
那我要旋转3次怎么办
先旋转1次
再旋转2次
所以这样做的一个好处是
我的密要
可以比原来存储的大量的减少
对不对
我不用存储原来那么多的密要
我只需要存储2的密次不长的密要
但它问题是什么呢
旋转的次数又变多了
对不对
原来我只需要一步到位
现在我要先旋转1次
再旋转2次
所以旋转
它本身就是一个
计算和存储的一个全衡
好 那么讲这么多
我们通过一个例子
来讲一下旋转的一个过程
假设现在有一个相量
是95816
好 那么
我取的这个密文的魔数
是6537
好 那么由于
这是四个明文的值
那么自然n应该取多少
取8
那在n等于8下
它的本源单位跟幼稚多少呢
好 留给大家做思考
好吗
好 那这里面
我们首先按照老办法
对这几个值进行编码
由于它都是实数
刚才我说的
已经收过了
把实数重新倒着再写一遍
就行了
对不对
然后呢 用跟
集齐功恶
对它进行编码
对吧
好 这里面
刚才已经埋下了一个伏笔
它的本源单位跟到底是多少
所以这里面就有体现
这里面不展开讲了 好吧
那么我们把它编码
成一个多样式
分别就是这样一个多样式
好 那么别忘了
我们编码完之后
要进行缩放 对不对
缩放完以后
它就是这样一个多样式
在缩放完以后得到的这个多样式
我们就可以对它进行加密 对吧
那么加密我们需要密要
需要噪声
这里为了简单起见
噪声等于零
就是为了简单起见
实际是不可以的
好 那么现在计算它的
B的值
直接进行加密的计算
从而得到了一个密文
它的一个结果 对不对
那么这里面你发现
这个密文的结果
每一个多样式的系数
都不会超过65537的 对不对
因为这是
在球的过程当中
如果超过就要对它进行取磨
好 那么现在
要对它进行左旋移位的操作
我们把它里面的位定源
从x变成x的5次方
对不对 这里面k等于1
对吧
然后用x5次方
替代多样式中的x
得到这样一个结果
好 那么目的是为了得到
宣传5次的旋转
旋转左旋移位以后的明文
所以这个mx5次方
实际上就是为了得到
左旋移位的明文
原来是零一零零零
现在变成一零零零零
得到这样一个效果
好 那么看具体
去怎么去操作它
我们把所有的x
变成x的5次方以后
那么对多样式
一定要记住进行取磨
取磨一是
因为你变成x5次方
有一些系数
它的这个位定源
它的x可能会超过8
对不对
就x次数会超过8
所以我要磨x的8次方加1
同时系数超过65537
要磨65537
就是这个意思
保证多样式的系数
以及多样式的次数都不超过
分别不超过65537和8
好了
那我要证明这解密
刚才我们说过
要有一个旋转的密钥
那么旋转密钥
实际上非常简单
构造起来很简单
就是把s
对吧
用s的5次方进行替代
同时呢
把这个s的
这个x的5次方切换为sx
目的是为了用s
能够直接对这个
旋转以后的多样式进行解密
和我们刚才重新一些话
那个构造的方式是非常类似
可以说是一样的
对不对
那么这里面
构造完之后
得到的密文多样式
就可以
旋转以后的密文
就可以通过这种方式来进行构造
好了
为了方便演示
这里面我们直接取a等于1
evk的造声等于0
然后用原始密钥
完成解密得到mpx
大家可以验证一下
这个mpx的结果
是不是我这里写的这样一个结果
那么这里面
这个mpx
它是原来的mx
你发现细数什么的都不一样
对不对
但是你把它结码以后
你发现
它结码以后
就是完成了一次
左旋的操作
变成了5,8,169
我们可以自行去看
这个解密以后
结码以后
是不是这样一个结果
那么
说这个旋转的一个过程
你发现是什么过程
我们总结一下
虽然它比较复杂
但大体上可以分为
先做自同后
对不对
这里面自同后的意思就是
我把x变成x的5次方以后
那么有些细数
它的位置就变了
对不对
因为我们的位定远
它的次数升高了
对吧
然后变成x的5次方以后
我们需要再怎么办
有一个旋转密钥
这个旋转密钥
就是用s来加密s的5次方
就是sx
来加密sx的5次方
这样一个断绕式
对不对
好那么加密完以后
得到旋转密钥
旋转密钥再和原来的
我们的多样式的旋转
以后的多样式做运算
运算完之后
得到旋转以后的多样式
那么旋转以后的密钥
多样式在进行解密
再进行解码
得到的明文
就是相比原来的明文
旋转一位以后的一个结果
那么旋转
它是非常重要的一步操作
这里面要提醒大家
旋转它的作用
尤其是在AI里面
我们要做
有很多成绩求合这样的操作
那么成绩求合
就是通过大量的旋转
来进行操作
因为密文的多样式的系数
是不能够直接求合的
必须要通过这种旋转操作
再把多样式同态加起来
对不对
才能够得到
成绩求合的
实际的明文的结果
好那么这里面
正好下一个
最后一个步骤
就是同态的加法
在运算的最后一个步骤
同态的加法
我旋转完之后
密文加起来
再进行解密
那一定就是
相当于明文相加的结果了
那么同态加
相对来说非常简单
我们用S加密的
两个密文C1和C2
把他们进行同态加
就是把两个多样式
对应的位置相加
比如说两个B相加
B1加B2
两个A相加
A1加A2
解密以后的结果
就是M1加M2
外带一个比较小的噪声
好了
最后一个步骤
解密
解码
那么比如说
我们做完了一系列的
运算以后
那么想要对它进行解密
好
那么我们解密怎么去计算呢
非常简单
就是B加AS
再码Q
就可以了
那么用我们刚才的
编码加密那个例子
得到的密文多样式
对它进行解密
得到了合约来的这个
这个
合约来的这个明文
是一模一样的
对不对
然后解密完了以后
由于我们这个
明文是缩放以后的一个结果
把它再缩放回来
也就是除以这个dirt
对不对
缩放回来
变成实际的明文
那么得到实际的明文
多样式在对它进行解码
那么解码就相对来说
非常简单的一个步骤
把所有的这个本源单位跟
带入到明文多样式里边
得到的就是结果
比如说
我们刚才编码的是
是四个附属
对不对
分别是3加4i
2-1i
好
那么我们把这几个
本源单位跟的值
带入以后
得到的正好
就是这四个明文的幅数值
当然我们后两个
就可以不需要了
然后呢
只取前两个
这是我要的结果
你可能会有疑问
这里面怎么和
原来的3加4i
和2-1i不太一样了
这就是我们CKS
它的算法
就是基于这种
近似计算的方式
这里面你可以理解
为什么我要成一个dirt
它最后再除这个dirt
回来
对不对
整个的这个过程当中
由于引入了造声
但是造声和dirt相比
非常小
那我们的造声
dirt以后
它所起的作用就微乎其微
但是不和原来一模一样
比如说这里边
2.98和原来的3
就差了0.02的这样一个造声
对不对
所以在过程当中
这个dirt可以起到
降噪的目的
就在这里面有体现
好了
那么最后
对它进行这个
这个提取的操作
就是把我们的这四个数
四个数变成
这个两个数
把前两个提取出来
在这一步
应设
投射到
这个二分之一
这样一个空间范围之内
但是大家不用去深究
为什么它叫投射
我们只需要知道
我们把它的前两个数
提取出来就可以了
好的
那么我们刚才讲完了
CKS算法
它的核心的步骤
并且举了例子来
比如说CKS下的这个
密太查询
来讲解了
它的具体的计算过程
那么从这个过程里会发现
实际还是蛮复杂的
对不对
这就是同台加密
所存在的问题
它的问题就是计算开销大
所以现在我们国内有很多
学者
包括蚂蚁
也在做怎么样去通过
软硬件协同的手段
去降低它的开销
它的开销之所以大
是因为我们计算的过程当中
要给
明文在里面隐藏着
要给明文的增长
流出足够的空间
所以它的密文
魔术会取得非常非常大
那也就是说
我们原来
明文可能占一个很小的空间
由于这个密文魔术
为了掩盖明文
导致密文的多像式
它的占的空间
会大幅的膨胀
原来
以你的一个敏感信息
它的一个体量
整个就是30.5KB
那么加密以后
它的密文
所有的密文
满足一个应用
完成一个应用
把所有的密文加密
变成密文
它的密文可能
达到一个电影的一个大小
一部高清电影的一个大小
对它密文的膨胀
是非常非常大
所以
它距离实际的应用
还是有着
比较大的这个差距的
它可以比
敏文的密文计算下
在CPU上
可以比敏文下降
4个数量级
它的性能
比如说
原来
我们
假设需要1秒
就把一个敏文计算完了
现在需要1万秒
对这个时间
会非常非常长
所以现在
所以现在也有很多学者
在从事清晒加密的
一个算法的优化
以及设计专用的硬件
来提升它的性能
那么这里面
我们看一下
要想支持清晒加密
它的一个高速的执行
那么在计算性能层面上
需要理论上
达到一个什么样的一个
计算的一个
性能的一个提升
以及存储待宽的一个提升
那我们对
清晒加密的这样一个
4个应用
做一下分析
好 那我们发现
原来在为加密的时候
那么敏文它的时间
可能是这样一个时间
那么密文的时间
就会变成这样一个时间
也就是说
它的计算性能要
理论上
能够比原来
计算敏文的性能
提升这么多倍
才能够在保证一定的
实时性
实时的完成
这个密文下的计算
那在待宽层面上
也是如此
因为总的存储器
的访问的待宽
这个为加密的情况下
我可能只需要
访问这么多
这个存储器的存储资源
但是我现在
如果要是变成
加密状态下
就变成一部电影的场度了
对不对
那么理论上
我要想支持
实时的这个数据的传输
我理论上的待宽需求
需要达到这么大
这个大家不知道
有没有概念
要达到这样大的一个待宽
现在我们没有任何一个
这个存储器
可以达到这样一个待宽
比如说我们现在
在数据中心里面
放的一个一个的PCA加速卡
那待宽
都达不到这样一个待宽
所以现在
距离实际的商用
还有很大的差距
也体现在这里
就是我们对待宽
和计算资源
都要求非常高
那么所以必须要设计
一些专用的硬件架构
来完成
这个全台价密的
一个高性能的计算
好 那这里面
微极的它的这个
为什么会造成
这么大的一个计算的
这个要求
那么对它的算子进行一下拆解
那这里面有非常重要的一步操作
叫做快速数论变换
这个是把一个多样式
在做惩罚的时候
比如说我们刚才说的
Fu的A乘以S
加M再加E
对不对
再比如说我们刚才做
重新的话里面
有A1B1等等
像这样一系列的计算
我们直接
做多样式的计算
它的复杂度很高
所以往往要把它
做这种快速数论变换
就类似我们
以前所学过的
Fu连变换一样
降低它的复杂度
那么现在我们
通过NDT变换以后
变成了两个多样式
就变成了点值表示
它们之间可以直接做惩罚
复杂度可以大幅的降低
所以这是它的一个好处
所以由于多样式的惩罚
运算在整个的这个
全台价密的算法里面
非常的多
所以NDT也会很多
那么因为每次做惩罚
你都要把它先变成
这个NDT的形式
才能方便的
以一种比较小的复杂度
来做惩罚运算
所以有一些论文里面
它的数据体现出
NDT能够占据
整个全台价密
计算的占比的50%以上
有一半以上都在做这种运算
那么NDT里边
占比最大的又是
取模的操作
那么我们做NDT
它的占比很高
取模它的开销
又占NDT的
一个非常大的一个比重
这里面我们的数据
是大概40%左右
所以我们是不是能够通过
对NDT这样核心的算子
来做一些优化
能够降低它的计算的开销呢
所以我们可以采用一种
这种多机的NDT的方式
这个不是什么新概念
在很早的
在复杂变换的时候
就有这种多机的变换
我们以前所学的
复杂变换都是以二为基
对不对
那么现在我们可以以八为基
如果是以多机的一个NDT
就可以减少里面
取模运算的次数
比如说现在我们
每一个这种小箭头
这是一个NDT
或者复杂变换
FFT
它的一个碟形运算的一个表示
那么这里面
每一个箭头都要取模
每做一次都要取模
那如果我们使用
这种多机的NDT的话
可以把它进行融合
只在最后一个次数
最后一个阶段取模
所以取模又原来在这里面
是12
对吧
12345678
24次取模运算
只减少到了8次取模运算
所以可以减少3次的取模
可以减少1¾的取模
所以减少1¾取模
也意味着我可以省掉什么
取模次数变为原来的1¾
那也意味着我可以省掉
1¾的取模时间
对不对
所以大大的提高了
NDT的一个计算性的
所以这是可以它优化的一个点
那么如果我们使用
这种多机的NDT
相比于以二维机这样的一个
NDT的话
它的时间明显的比原来减少
从这个数据里面
就可以明显的看出来
整个应用的运行时间
就可以明显减少
大概2到3倍左右
好那么
我们可以通过
这种算法优化的手段
来减少计算的开销
那么对于带宽
这怎么办呢
这个可能就没有什么办法了
因为如果
我们想要提升带宽
那只能从硬件的角度去下手
对不对
当然我们可以从软件
去对它进行压缩
那是一个手段
但是我们从硬件上
我们也可以去进行
这个大带宽的存储器的一个使用
比方说
用高带宽内存
叫HBM
对不对
那么我们也
这个基于高带宽内存的
一个IPG的器件
做了一个圆形
就是成功态处理器的一个圆形
这个圆形它的作用
就是通过这样一个
硬件加速
来提供的大带宽
以及可以定制化的这样一个特点
来加速群众态的一个计算
那么我们在这个加速场上
做了一些测试
那么测试的效果
可以说还算可以
但是也没有达到
可以商用的这种水平
我们发现测试了以后
它的性能提升了大概
20多位左右吧
实际上要想
真正让全开加密
能够进行商用
还得继续的提升两个数量级
我觉得才可以
这是它的一些
实际的测试的效果
提升十几二十倍
大概是这样一个量级
那么在IPG上
因为它的资源比较有限
而且IPG它的频率也比较低
所以这个方面
是造成了
有一定的性能的限制
虽然它有大的存储器的带宽
比如说这个旗舰里面
就有HBM
但是这个旗舰资源
往往也比较少
所以它的性能提升的
也是比较有限的
所以现在有很多学者
在设计这种专用的集成链路
提出一些圆形的设计
来通过设计一些大芯片的
一些手段
来提升它的性能
好 后面是一些数据
我就快速的去略过
那么同时
为了方便编程
还需要一些计算库
那么一些密文计算
加密 还有编码等等
如果你自己手动一个一个去写
那这个带码量太大了
对不对
所以需要一定的库
来进行这个
方便用户进行编程
现在群伦态的加密库
有很多
比方说微软的seal库
还有这个OpenFH1
这样的开源库等等
所有的群伦态加密库
大部分都是开源的
那我们也自己
开发了一个群伦态的
一个计算库
叫波塞东
这是波塞东的链接
大家感兴趣的话
可以去看一看这个库
它的一些特点
就是里面集成的硬件库
软件使用起来
是标准的世界家语言
提供的API
那么使用起来
让你感觉会非常的规整
就是你知道这个API
它的一些参数是做什么用的
你直接往里给它输入参数
也就可以了
所以它使用起来
相对于seal来说
是更为方便一些
但是它的速度
可能现在还没有达到
像OpenFH1或者是
这个TFH1
这些主流的库这么快
因为它底层内部
还是有一些多线长大等等
还没有充分的利用起来
这个硬件的资源
那么这个库
这是还有我们的底层硬件
可以用来支持
我们的银语的框架
那么银语它里面
也有一些基于FH1的
也就是基于全台加密的
这种多方安全计算的一些协议
那么可以通过这个
我们底层的这些算算子库
还有底层的硬件来
支持上层的野色计算的框架
这里打个比方
因为我们可以用这个库达
和库DN来支持什么
TensorFlow、PyTorch等等这些
AI的库一样
那么如果我们有
全台加密的底层的计算卡
在配合上它的算子库
我们也可以支持像银语
这样的各种优秀的
隐私计算的框架
那这个呢
是我们波塞东库
所提供的一些API
这个我就不详细介绍了
我们快速的过一下
如果大家感兴趣
就去我们的这个在线文档上
去看它详细的使用方法
那这里面呢
是参数的配置
比如说我们配置
刚才所讲到的这个
多样式的Degre
比如说这里面配置成4096
它要配置成它的
要一次能够编码加密多少个数
比如说加密是2.14四方
这么多个数
还有这个一些密文的魔术
等等在这里面
都可以进行先用的配置
也就是直接把这些值
给它配置到
我们的这个数据结构里就可以
使用起来也非常的简单
这是编码的一些API的函数
像cxs encoder
还有decoder等等
就可以直接使用
还有这是加解密的一些API
可以通过这种
这个密文的这个密钥的多样式
然后把它复制给我们的
加解密函数
就可以实现
实现这种相应的加解密
那这个呢
是提供各种各样的
评估函数
也就是我们之前
前级PVT里面说的那个LF
那个F呢
它可以是各种各样的
这种形态
可能是非线性的
那我们通过这里面
所提供的评估函数
可以去拟合
那些非线性的函数形态
那这个呢
就是我们评估函数
所提供的各种各样的这个API
在这里面
包含我们前面所讲解的
密文惩罚
还有这个重现性化
还有旋转等等
那么在实现一个
复杂的非线性函数的时候
那么我们大家可以去按区
去调用这里面的函数
来实现一个非线性的函数
那么这个呢
是其他的一些
比如做这个NGT
还有做这个切换密钥等等
一些操作的API
我们的库里边也都有提供
我们也不仅支持CKS
这一种算法
还支持BFV BGV
这是都是非常主流的
基于算数议算的
全导弹加密算法
在我们的库里边
也都是支持的
这是BFV的
一些核心的API
好那
我们通过一个例子
看一下我们波塞东
在实际的业务场景里边
做一个前面有所讲的
两方的密探查询
它的一个场景
场景的一个演示
好首先
左边最蓝是
这个查询方
服务器和客户端
这是查询方
右边是背查询方
双方先进行握手
交换一些
这个公要
因为我们在查询过程中
有很多需要换密钥等等
需要我们的查询方
来提供一些公要
首先发起PIR的任务
两方建立了连接
建立连接以后交换公要
还有一些查询矩认的
一些大小等等
这里面就是一些公要
比如说旋转密钥等等
都发送给服务器端
都发送给背查询方
公要交换完了以后
那么由于在云端
部署了我们的加速卡
我们在加速卡上
做一些出手化的工作
然后在卡上进行查询的运算
我们要查询的一个值
是这个值
你看就是在我们的服务器里边
有这个值
第12个所以
对不对
我发现值是基本上一样的
有一定的误差
可以进去到小数点
后第6第7位
对吧
所以这个过程是一个非常
非常简单的一个demo
它是就是通过这种
我们之前所介绍的
整个我们今天这一次talk
所介绍的全部的算法
还有一些硬件
去搭建的一个掩饰系统
这里面成功的查询出来
我们要查询的数据
这个过程后我们
之前所讲的那个例子
是一模一样的
就是一个简单的demo
给大家看一下
最后在这一次talk
结束之前说一下
对于未来的一些畅想
实际圈奈加密
在世界范围之内
是一个非常火热的学科方向
美国早在2019年
就联合一些巨头
比方说英特尔和微软
去从事圈奈加密的
软件的设定研发
在韩国是有算法的发源地
一些非常主流的
圈奈加密算法
比方说CKS
都是韩国的学者
首先提出的
那么欧洲
以比利时卢文大学
还有扎马公司为代表
那么在我们国内
以蚂蚁集团为代表
蚂蚁集团在这个方面的研究
也是非常的领先的
所以我希望
有越来越多的同学们
能够从事这个方向的
软件设计
相关领域的研发工作
那为我们国家在这个领域
它的快速发展
那么贡献出自己的力量
此外呢
由于时间关系
在这一次talk上
没有提到的一些知识点
在这里也一并给大家提一下
比方说CKS
还有RNS的表示
现在的软件设计
基本上都是通过
RNS表示来展开的
所以这里给大家提供
一个参考文献
另外自举
是非常重要的一个步骤
那么自举的开销比较大
那么如何进行自举的插入
是非常重要的一个topic
所以现在有很多
做这个编译器的学者
在提出一些自动
自举插入的一些方法
也给大家提供一个参考文献
那么总是FHE的性能提升
还有很长的路要走
那么我觉得必须要通过
软件协同设计的手段
才能够真正达到
它性能提升的一个目标
所以我团队
也在这个方面做了
相关的研究
也有一些相关的研究成果
放在了我的主页上
也欢迎大家前去学习
并批评指证
好 那我今天的talk
就到这里
再次感谢银语的邀请
谢谢同学们的观看
再见